please ensure you
reference your page or paragraph number
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
when invited to speak please ensure you
turn on your microphone
now may ask officers taking part in the
meeting to introduce themselves starting
with mr lee please
good evening members i'm matthew lee
lead specialist place
and chief plan officer at walden
district council thank you very much
thank you and
uh miss matthews
good evening chairman yes i'm catherine
matthews um
uh specialist in development management
thank you
thank you um miss marvin mr mrs i do
apologize if i get those the wrong way
around
then please correct me if you right
good evening members i'm sophie martin
and i'm a caseworker for development
management
thank you good evening members my name
is katie fuller i'm clark to this
evening's committee
thank you uh are there any other
officers present who weren't a part of
this meeting as distinct from background
support
okay i'll take that as a no before i
call on the clock to take the roll call
of committee members
and i asked those councillors who are in
attendance to introduce themselves
please and councillor morris i know is
here
good evening everybody councilor maurice
in attendance thank you
thank you uh anybody else i'm not seeing
anyone else
okay i think we'll move on so mrs fuller
can you please carry out the roll call
of
members to confirm i was in attendance
yes chairman members i'll call your name
please could you indicate if you are
present starting with counsellor durham
please
i'm present thank you councillor mrs
fleming
president katie thank you thank you
councillor jarvis
evening casey chairman members thank you
councillor keys good evening kindly
chairman members thank you
councillor morley
good evening everyone present thank you
councillor mrs thompson
oh i'm here thank you sorry thank you
councillor miss white
thank you i'm here thank you
sorry i'm sorry there was an issue
apparently with the sound
it is only housekeeping so some of the
intro didn't
go out i'm actually going to carry on
because um
the warnings just in case anyone did
miss the warnings about recording
members of the public we actually don't
have any present in the meeting so
um i don't think that's an issue i hope
you all agree members
i'll go through it all again if you'd
like to
no i didn't think so thank you um
right so the next thing is apologies for
absolute blessings as well
uh yes chairman we've received apologies
from councillor siddall
thank you uh item three is the minutes
in the 10th of february uh it's
recommended the minutes of the meeting
held on the 10th of february
found on purchase 1716 are approved as a
true and accurate record
iso move if you wish to second that
motion please unmute your microphone and
stay tuned on now
seconded councillor fleming thank you
right if any member wishes to raise any
matter of accuracy please use the hands
up function to indicate
oh we did just to note we did go through
the recording again
and um the minutes were correct in the
order of
uh the matter that councillor siddal
raised because councillor darren had in
fact
spoken very briefly earlier on um
but you know this isn't hansard so we
don't take it down
for dating uh right so the next thing
uh sorry no i haven't done that can we
do that by sent members anybody disagree
yeah everybody's happy thank you very
much uh for his declarations of interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraph 628
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members members are reminded they're
also required to disclose any such
interests as soon as they become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the hands up function now to
indicate and i will invite you to speak
councillor darwin yeah thank you
chairman uh usual declaration as a
member of ethics county council
who are statutory consultees in respect
for some elements of planning thank you
okay thank you very much no one else
in that case we move on to our first
planning application which is item
five the essex wildlife plus nature
reserve blue house farm
uh which is in north cambridge
uh right i'm going to ask the officer to
present the item
and members of just a reminder if you
wish to speak please make this known
using the
hands function
okay thank you for the message counselor
dharmal get back to that
um yes i think we're on this massive
please if you would be so kind
to give us the presentation thank you
chairman
members
apologies for their
is that available for everyone to see i
can see that thank you i hope everyone
else can
okay
okay so so this is an application
um for the construction of an earth bund
um and some foot drain stitches
and 12 shallow scrapes and the breaking
up of land drains
and the construction of our border
sluice this is the essex wildlife tres
nature reserve blue house farm blue
house farm chase
in north america so that drawing shows
the um the location of the application
site outlined in red roughly outliving
red
and then you can see um where the site
relates to north van bridge so the
access to the site
is um along
along these chairs here which is also
public footpaths
and when you get into the world the
reserve um just off um blue house farm
chase
so the and the application site extends
to around 20 hectares
um located east of north pambridge the
entire reserve
um is 240 hectares and the majority is
within
a triple s i ramsar site
and a special protection area
um and these designations are primarily
based on the importance of reserves
populations of wintering and breeding
wildfire and waders
and then you've got river the river
crouch um about 150 miles
meters south of the site and which is is
subject to further wildlife designations
the site is within
flood zone 3a high probability of
flooding but is mostly protected by
existing tidal defenses
and the site at the moment is um
improved grassland
and there is an existing bund along the
northern and eastern peripheries of the
site
and i've talked about access to the site
and from blue um
blue house farm chase um
and there is a also a permissive
footpath into the reserve
from the chase site levels with insight
range
from um about half a meter
aond um to the southeast and
nearly two meters aod along the
northwestern periphery
so that's a difference of um just
about a meter and a half the nearest
building to the application site
is around 220 meters
to the west of the proposed
bund but that one is within the
applicant's own ship
the closest third party properties are
residential dwellings 355
355 meters northwest along the chase
right so
this is um a bigger version of the
location plan
and the blue line there is the extent of
the
wildlife trust and reserve
so um as i said before it's um
the application is to um create
approximately um three kilometers of
foot drain stitches
um and there is also the earthbound
which will go around the periphery of
the site
which will extend to just over two
kilometers in length
and the bend would only be um half a
meter in height
and but four meters wide um
what and sorry
all right sorry my fault
you're right something in the background
i apologize
okay and so this this plan shows the
um application site and the um the blue
lines
vertical lines are the land rains and
the blue circles or the scrapes
where the um and the scrapes would be
about a half a meter in
depth though there'd be under shallow
areas and
the essay the bundle go all the way
around the outside
and the orange rectangle there is where
the
sluice would be be located
and you've also got the land right
excavations there
indicated with that the little black um
symbol so the the idea of the proposal
is to
create wetland habitat for breeding and
overweighting war file and waders
the aim is to the project is to create
um areas of shallow flooding
and standing water that was seasonally
dry out
um creating muddy um wet grassland
habitat for a range of birds
associated with these habitats the
importer material would not be required
to construct the bund
as the earth removed to create the foot
drains and the scrapes could be
would be used and the works would be
carried out during october november
to avoid the ground nesting bird
breeding season
these are some crush sections desserts
illustrative to show
the um the scrapes and
and the new buns that would be created
and also the sluice gate
some photos typical photos of the area
um with the existing bend on the top
left there
and um with the river crowd to be on
on the to the right
and so in conclusion um the application
has been
assessed and all the status control teas
none of the statutory conditions council
teas have raised any objections
so um it's considered to be accepted in
principle it would not cause harm to the
current appearance of the area
as particularly as in bank whether or
not non-typical
feature of the area there'll be no loss
of existing vegetation
and the immunity of local residents
would not be
adversely affected subject to the
imposition of conditions as recommended
um no objections raised in relation to
the impact works on flood risk
or highway safety and the proposal would
actually result in enhancements in
relation to nature conservation
and under this basis is recommended that
their permission is granted again
subject to conditions as set out in your
papers
thank you chairman thank you the
recommendation
um as we've just been told is to approve
i'm actually not gonna put that
um i'm gonna hold my fire until we've
had a little bit of a discussion so we
don't end up
potentially nowhere to go back to um
i've got three hands up two of the board
members
so um councillor fleming councillor
white would one if you like to
go first councillor white had a hand up
for us
yes thank you and just say i called this
to committee
um because i had a lot of concerns
obviously with all the flooding and
everything else and i'm not
keen on uh removing um
good ground and flooding it out but
actually i've spoken to a lot of the
locals and i i have to say thank you to
the officer for being very patient with
me but
i wanted to get this one right she
doesn't want to make a mistake and
actually after looking into it more
thoroughly
and speaking to a lot of locals and they
haven't objected so i'm happy to go with
the recommendation
thank you thank you councillor fleming
thank you chair i just wanted to ask
catherine if she had consulted with
angelian water at all
through chairman i just need to check
the support if
um if they were consorted it would be
um referenced under the list of uh
consultants
no they weren't
um just back through you chair um
catherine i know that they've angling
water have been doing
a lot of work in the village um
because of the surface water problems in
the village
um so i was a little bit surprised not
to see
anything there from them but i see that
essex suds have been consulted and they
have
haven't raised any objections so are you
entirely happy
that that has been squared away the
surface water
drainage issues in the village
well the yes and they said certainly
they said
um looked at the application and they um
they did come back some questions that
the applicant has has
um addressed um and i mean the idea of
the scheme
is to actually keep more water on site
for longer
um so it does have the potential for
um helping with you know flood
so when so when the that site gets gets
uh flooded the the water is retained um
for longer um so
certainly in terms of surface water
drainage then um
there is anticipated to be no no issues
and certainly no
impact of offsite
thank you are you kids thank you
thank you yes thank you um
councillor fleming brought up some of my
concerns and they've been answered
with the building going on in the air in
the surface water that
could be created but it appears to be
addressed so that's fine thank you thank
you
um well i haven't spoken against it and
i don't think there's anyone else just
speaks at this point i will put the
recommendation
which is to approve could i have a
second look at that if anyone is happy
too
all right okay everyone's in there
counselor all he won
um right uh i think we better take a
roll call it's less messy in the end
um so mr could you just listen to the
names please
uh yes chairman um so members i'll take
your names
uh we are voting for the officer
recommendation to approve
the proposal subject to the conditions
as detailed in section 8 of the report
starting with councillor durham please
agree thank you councillor mrs fleming
four thank you councillor jarvis
thank you councillor keys four
thank you councillor morley
thank you councillor mrs thompson oh
thank you
thank you i miss white
thank you thank you chairman 97
for none against and no abstentions
thank you very much okay right items
uh sorry just to confirm so item
five of the essex wildlife trust
application
is is approved in line with the
officer's recommendation and report
so all those conditions in the report
will apply
so item six is tpo land to the west of
fiscally close gold hangar um
in a moment i'll call the officer to
present the item but
the usual reminder members to if you
wish to speak use the hands-on function
so ms martin if you could present a
report please
thank you chair
firstly by way of a verbal members
update the parish reference on page
35 of the agenda is incorrect and should
be gold hanger parish and not tulsian
darcy parish
thank you
confirmation of tpo 1520
including modifications to remove the
pine tree marked as t2 from the schedule
of the order
and also from the location plan of the
order
here is the original location plan with
the oat
tree t1 and the pine tree t2
here is the modified location plan
removing the pine tree
sorry here is the copy of the modified
order removing the pine tree from the
schedule of the order
here are some photographs of the oak
tree when looking west into fiscally
close
and some further photos when looking
west into thisly close
in september 2020 the council received
information from a member of public that
a tree located between three and four
this sea closed was going to be failed
imminently
the council's tree consultant identified
two trees at the site an
oak tree and a pine tree due to the
prominent location and the size of the
trees
it was considered that the removal of
the trees would materially impact on the
immunity of the area
and so the resulting tpo was served on
the 17th of september 2020 the order was
served as an emergency tpo
due to the imminent threat to the trees
this provides the council with a period
of assessment to be undertaken and
includes confirming the accuracy of the
plans
species and a wider consideration of the
amenity of the trees
from public vantage points following a
secondary site visit from the council
tree consultant
the officer has confirmed that the pine
tree has not been annotated correctly on
the location plan and sits further to
the west behind the largely landy tree
the pine tree is not visible within the
immediate street scene and is a young
tree which holds minimal
amenity value it was considered that it
would not be expedient to serve a tpo on
the pine tree
and therefore only the oak tree t1 on
the plan is worthy of protection
due to its size and prominent location
therefore the tpo has been modified to
remove the t2 pine tree from the order
one objection has been received from the
owner of the tree relating to the tpi
the owner of the tree has stated that he
never intended to remove the tree
and this was a misunderstanding by a
neighbour
the ejection from the owner has not been
resolved and whilst the intent of the
removal of the tree may
have been misconceived originally the
oak tree scored satisfactory
for its worthiness of a tpo due to its
immunity value alone and is still worthy
of protection
therefore the question of whether or not
to confirm the tpo has modified has been
bought before members to decide
due to its location and size it is
considered that the tree provides
significant amenity value to the
character and appearance of the area
and the tpo should be confirmed in line
with the modifications to prevent
inappropriate works being carried out
which could harm the immunity value and
health of the tree
thank you chair thank you very much
uh right well
this one i'm just going to put the
recommendation which is that the tpo be
confirmed which
it will only apply to the oak tree would
anyone second that
second dead counts for fleming thank you
councillor family
uh right i've got council of white and
council
jarvis ladies go first council right
thank you madam chairman and could we go
back to the map to see how far away the
oak tree is
from the house and the neighbouring
houses because i didn't quite catch that
and um the actual tempo scores that it
scored so
i don't recall seeing those
sorry i'll just get this larger for you
so the tempo it scored uh 14
out of 25 and it has to be 10
to be worthy of a tpi assessment
thank you okay if i might come back
how many meters from the house is it
because it's awfully close
because i know that tempo is supposed to
take into account the location and
likely future damage it's going to cause
to houses
i'm looking particularly at the one that
looks like it's to the north
so the is this the t2 tree
the t2 they both look
very close i'm just thinking about root
damage that's all
right um i'll just show you uh i don't
know if you can see here
um it might be easier this is the le
landy tree which doesn't have any
immunity value
so it is just this oak tree um this
photo might be
easier it's it's behind a fence and all
of this
area here is owned by the um
owner of two three fists these i think
i'm not sure on on the distance meters
would be
i'm not sure unfortunately because i
oat roots you can't have within 15
meters of a house it becomes
unmortgageable
um and really you want to be 20 meters
away and that's my concern
is for the other house owners is if it's
within 20 meters they can probably get
permission to take it down anyway
and that's why i wanted i can't tell
from the photo and i haven't had time to
drive out how far away it is
sorry i'm cutting because i'm trying to
google earth this and i'm not having a
lot of likes
i should have thought of google earth
but i think you know is the houses both
sides look very close
that that was my concern obviously i
don't know how far away it is
um actually since i can't share my
screen
um i'm just wondering if an officer
could possibly get this app on google
earth so
we can have a look at the satellite view
through your chair yes i can try and get
it up for you quickly that would be
wonderful
okay um in the meantime
um would you mind councillor white if i
just moved to councillor jarvis because
if you've got similarities um councillor
jarvis could you just
um yes thank you thank you chairman um
what was sort of trying to look at that
yeah i did note the um
i mean obviously i think we all know
eight trees are of a high
high value uh and you know clearly of
all the types of trees that we might be
able to
put a tpo on i think uh oak trees would
certainly score highly in
in sort of my calculation and obviously
this one already has
uh i think uh of course having a tpl
doesn't stop somebody
uh making some sort of alterations to
the tree if that's what they wish to do
to manage the tree so to speak but it
just protects the tree of course
her safe and being cut down so
i i think it's i mean it's difficult to
see the measurements from here where it
is it looks
as far away from the houses as it can be
if it if it's going to be within the
sort of property
domain so to speak so uh but obviously
we'll hear back from sophie in a minute
on that
um as far as the pine tree is concerned
well obviously that's not really up for
debate i did
i did wonder though there is another
enormous tree there presumably that's
the
landing and presumably nobody's nobody's
offering obviously to put a tpo on that
but
that seems uh even bigger um so i'm
surprised perhaps they haven't
at least commented on that there was
obviously a mix-up probably between that
and the pine tree i suspect so we might
get something else coming to us
in the future perhaps but i just really
wanted to comment on the oak tree
particularly
yes it would be something i'd be keen to
say unless there's a technical reason
that it's too close to the property
which is being explored thank you
thank you um i'm getting anywhere
with google earth i was a bit slow off
the mark i mean the big thing for me
about a tpo is that you can um
you know you can get a tree replaced
which if there isn't a tpo you
you can't so it doesn't prevent work
being done
um mr lee did you want to come in about
it i'm just gonna highlight the
ms mars and so raised her hand so she
yeah
yeah sorry he's wrong can you
zoom us in a bit on that yeah no problem
so okay here
that's the oak tree yes it just here
hmm
i wonder how old that would be
a few a handful of meters if that away
from the house i don't know if this is
me thinking i don't
know if that's there or not that looks
awfully close
it is awfully close um i would have said
though
that they're not looking to take it down
and on the assumption and i appreciate
you know a lot more about
trees in general than i do council of
white but you know if it could be
managed rather than
disposed of and still protect the house
that's certainly what i would hope to
see mr lee
and miss martin if you wanted to tell us
anything oops
mr lee
um i didn't realize that
sorry if i'm on mute but unfortunately
um i'm not allowed to be um as i was
really trying to echo what yourself and
councillor jarvis has raised about
the uh tree um and the fact that this
isn't and this is an application
application
or not an application this is a request
to
put a tpo on the tree to protect it it
doesn't stop
works happening in the future it doesn't
mean that
there could not be management and it
could even mean removal in the future if
it's found to be unacceptable
at the time um and that but as you said
this now allows us to protect that if we
impose this or serve this to
preservation order and i think
the fact that there may be some issues
in the future that aren't necessary
evidence before us now or aren't ready
for discussion now
isn't a reason per se to not serve the
tpo that would be for something for
consideration to if
and when it was sought to be removed and
we can then
replace it protect it if necessary and i
just think members need to consider is
does that tree you know that ms martin's
shown
have amenity value or not to the
character of the area i would advise
there's a
uh oak tree of a certain number of years
it really does thank you
thank you i i've got councillor durham
but just as the board member of just
popping
um gold hanger parish council are
extremely keen on their trees in their
in their village in their parish
um and we are hoping very much that
we'll
keep it um that tree will stay cancelled
yeah thank you i think you know looking
at it it's clearly of
aesthetic merit because it's on view at
the bottom of that
um road so it's it's quite a landmark
you know it in the great scheme of oak
trees it's actually quite a young tree
by the look of it you know
um in two or three hundred years time
it could it could be a different bowl
game um
quite clearly um but i think at the
moment there is sufficient merit to
warrant the tpo
and as we've already established and we
know that you know
if at some date in the future um
if it becomes a problem then it can be
revisited
but i think that it it deserves it
deserves this
this protection at the moment um you
know
we'll see what happens it would be
very clear on the photograph um down the
road
it you know it's it it apart from that
rotten laylander which needs
tipping over um that hopefully would um
you know
thank you um councillor white your hand
is up is that a legacy handle would you
like to come back
it's a legacy hand um but um
i i just say i i i have issues with
um how how close to the house it is so
so for me i i can't agree with the
recommendation but that's up to them
to decide okay thank you very much
um ron i put the recommendation because
like most planning applications this is
something we either
agree or we don't um so
given that the recommendation is to keep
the tpo
which will apply to the oak tree only um
and that was seconded wasn't it i can
remind myself yes so uh can we have
a roll call for the vote please mrs
fuller
yes chairman so we're voting to confirm
the tpo
with the modifications as per the report
members will take your name please can
you indicate whether you are for
against or abstaining councillor durham
please
thank you councillor mrs fleming
thank you councillor jarvis
thank you councillor keys
thank you councillor mrs thompson
oh thank you and councillor miss white
against thank you chairman that is six
four one against and no abstentions
thank you so just to confirm that tpo is
confirmed sorry about that um according
to
the record officer's recommendation item
seven
uh any other items of business the
chairman of the committee decides are
urgent you'll be delighted to hear there
are none
uh eight i'd make the closure of the
meeting members thank you for your
contributions
i now draw the meeting to a close with
thanks to all of you members
um to all officers uh whether background
or
committee um i'll close the meeting at
1834 that is pretty good members
thank you very much well done well done
thank you
good night everyone good night everyone
i have to say this
complete this is the meetings now